you
kyle the only one in his 20s figured it
out outside of sam
go figure man guy kyle's got a
old soul man we ready are we lying
we are live with episode number 34 and
this is the first time we're having two
toms on yes
tom center nice to see you and tom
ellsworth so i got to say zenner and
ells
as we're going through it just to
simplify stuff so tom you know you got a
nice shirt on you want to tell us why
you're wearing that shirt
oh yeah this is uh this is for frank
williams frank williams legendary
owner founder of formula one's williams
team
multiple world championships with
senate's last team tragically
but he just got out of the hospital he's
an older guy now but he's still out
there and he just got out of the
hospital
frank williams i hope you're doing well
williams fans everywhere just a little
tribute for frank cool do you think you
could change the oil in my rental car
in about 13 seconds you look like a pit
crew he could do a lot of things
this guy goes back just destroyed a
really good tribute dude oh i'm sorry
okay what a great way to start right no
no no no no on this today's podcast
we'll always know where we are you know
why
we got tom tom so that's a joke
if you're very smart and what age do you
have to be to get that joke
about 10 years ago years ago
okay so look we got a lot of things we
got a lot of things to cover
uh a lot of things to talk about here
today
um this will be the only podcast we'll
do this week just so everybody knows
this will be the only podcast we'll do
this week we got
the i think the week of words meaning
two people used two words that
shocked the marketplace which we'll talk
about one of them was tim cook
the other one was elon musk one was when
he was given a speech the other one was
on twitter
both of them skyrocketed their stock
which you got analysis you want to give
us about gm and tesla which is
interesting i can't wait to get that
data
that you have stimulus happened this
week okay i mean that's uh pretty much
in the works right now we got georgia
going on
record-breaking money that's being
raised we got nashville
that a catastrophic event happens at at
t maybe you can kind of give us a
rundown and tell us what's going on
because there's a lot of
stories connections mommies sues it's
very very weird
on what's going over there fauci and
rubio's uh
you know little fight that they had over
twitter you know fauci is being called
liar by marco rubio and then everybody
on the other side is coming and saying
how dare you call fauci a liar where
your president's the biggest liar it's a
very interesting thing that's going on
there
chinese journalists who documented wuhan
coronavirus outbreak
jailed for four years okay jail for four
years for simply saying
what happened but she's going to jail by
the way that's a little high uh
if you guys raise it it's very high now
for me uh china regulators tell ant
group to overhaul businesses which is
alibaba they're trying to break them
apart and maybe we'll get into that a
little bit later
uh top earners biggest ceos how much
money they're making you'll be surprised
to see what the biggest ceos
in america's salary is and what kind of
money they're making and then you know
gm
we'll talk about that apple i already
said uh let me see what else i got oh
one
uh wonder woman uh uh opening day
mario just said something very
interesting i wish you guys could have
heard and mario said
it is the biggest pandemic opening
of the year biggest movie the big
is that what mario said mario i want to
quote you correctly can you please say
what you said
it's the biggest opening during the
pandemic we want to quote mario
correctly
biggest opening during the pandemic for
any movie
how many movies are on that leader one
movie but it's the biggest oh no we've
had more movies but but it's what it's
the biggest
35 million so they're wrong in their
numbers all right we'll see what's going
to happen but mario is very protective
of wonder woman which we appreciate
we appreciate that and i think tom
cruise had another mix up but anyway so
we got a lot of things to go through
here
how about we start off with uh uh you
know uh
uh we start off with georgia and kind of
go through what's been happening and how
much money was raised so here's how it's
looking like right now
all four uh senate candidates in runoff
election are raising record funds led by
one democrat
rolling in the doe according to politico
ossoff brought in 106.8 million dollars
in two months
making him the best funded senate
candidate in history
his opponent david perdue brought in 68
million dollars
in the same time frame now ossoff is the
democrat produced a republican in the
other race
warnock brought in 103.4 million dollars
while republican kelly loffler
raised only 64. so the democrats have
raised 40 million dollars more
than the republicans so far the previous
fundraising record
for a u.s senate candidate was held by
democrat jamie harrison who raised 57
million
in his unsuccessful bid to defeat
senator lindsey graham in south carolina
all four of the georgia candidates
easily
surpassed that number having said that
tom thoughts
ellsworth um i think they got it all
wrong
there are exactly 11 million people that
live in the state of georgia
11 million okay and listen to what was
raised
why doesn't somebody just send every
single one of them a 20 starbucks card
they could literally do that that's
right with all this money they could
they could have just they could have
said listen this one would do
i think i think it's amazing it's it's a
testimony to what's hanging in the
balance and what's hanging the balance
is the u.s senate
and conservative or liberal legislative
principles
that's it zener what do you think you
know i'm glad i don't live in georgia
that's all i can say
i hate political ads and can you imagine
how you're being it would ruin your
holidays
it would be the absolute worst now
here's the craziest thing about it these
democratic candidates
are raising so much money it's it's
literally insane
over 100 million for one candidate for
one race
but yesterday one of the narratives is
they're running out of money
that they're gonna have to choose pretty
soon between boots on the ground it
sounds like a war doesn't it
or tv ads and chuck schumer even came
out and said that he's quote unquote
pessimistic he tried to back
away from that comment a little bit but
pessimistic about the democratic chances
now they have to run the table the
democrats in georgia they're going to
win both of them
right so the republicans only have to
win one there are so many interesting
subplots to this loffler you know who's
a very very uh
successful established credible person
getting torched
by the nba the wnba she's an owner in
the wnba
and they have from her team and the
entire league have basically mobilized
to
to try to take her down tick talkers let
me tell you credit to tick-tockers i
mean people cannot downplay the tick
tock
game it's insane i mean they had a hand
in the in the regular election
even leading into the debates and into
the primaries and even now now i will
say this happily there are some
republican-based
twit uh tick-tock groups too because you
only hear about the the little liberals
that are out there trying to
stream things up that there's like one
conservative one that has 1.5 million
followers on theirs
so it looks like it's both ways but
tick-tock i mean everything is going to
make a difference in this this election
because so much is at stake
yeah so here's here's here's what i can
tell you what i what i notice
i have given money to both republicans
and democrats
okay i've given money to both sides so i
receive email from both sides
okay i get emails from republicans that
send me money talking about georgia i
get emails from democrats telling me
i have to tell you for every one email i
get
from republicans i get eight emails from
democrats
and the way they do it is so creative
they'll get different people
sending the emails and they'll say
you know one of them will say dnc
headquarters okay and obviously you know
that's coming straight from the nc
headquarters
i get that but then the rest will say
different names
james taylor michelle obama chuck
schumer
nancy pelosi they have a hundred names
that i get emails from so every time i
open it up and they'll say
patrick this year i went all in and
helping out like job
and then they'll go into this georgia
would you donate seven dollars directly
to dnc to flip georgia fund to help win
the runoffs elect the democratic control
senate and win a
essential races in a month so here's the
point i'm trying to make to you somebody
may say well pam why would you give to
both parties
strategically for me i want to learn
what both sides are doing that's one
two the approach that republicans are
taking versus democrats
i got to tell you democrats are playing
more often than republicans are
and and whether there is a part of this
where there is this confidence
to say we have it don't even worry about
it that's the problem sometimes when you
get too cocky
we have it don't even worry about it
where the republicans are going to pick
it up
listen there's no way in the world we're
going to lose both seats so they're not
playing offense
so they're raising 40 million less but
we know this week trump is going to
georgia i think january 40 is going to
be in georgia
to help those guys out who do you think
is going to end up winning here the way
it's looking like right now
god i i hope the republican republicans
are you hopeful are you are you like if
you want to put the logical
hat and you're betting money right now
are you betting your hundred thousand
dollars on republicans winning or are
you betting on democrats 100 i'm betting
on the democrats
absolutely they've been harvesting votes
for weeks out there they've already got
two million votes
that are already in right um the way
they've learned to play
dirty they've developed the the the
playbook
so they're just gonna you know apply it
to georgia here right now no i'm very
very worried
you know i'm not optimistic at all and
every day i accept expect something bad
or or crazy to come out
i mean there's even some sort of crazy
tie-ins to the explosion in nashville
which we could talk about a little bit
later but no i would say the democrats
are probably gonna win this thing just
like they won in november
tom i so
what's good for america i'm gonna set my
views aside what's good for america
i think is a divided government that is
almost kind of neutralized against
itself so it doesn't sway
too far in either direction i think
that's good for america i get the
feeling kelly lauthler is probably going
to win
her race by a nose which basically
will make that happen but i agree with
you the there has been so much effort
out there
it's tough to drop the fraud word um
without
stuff right in front of me but um you
know when you see that 82 percent of
confederate soldiers have voted
you know i'm um i'm thinking you know
there's things going on
you know i wonder if these tick tockers
do they really know
all the ramifications of what they're
trying to do and how it ultimately will
affect them i mean if this country
is run exclusively by the left it's not
great for every anybody really
truly except a lifelong politician maybe
people that want to have just absolute
power but it's so funny these guys are
so motivated and they do have
power and they do have influence and
they do have the energy to do this but
you sometimes wonder they're so young do
they even know what they're doing
it looks like they need to have an adult
in the room you know kind of guiding him
okay there's some repercussions here
for what you're trying to do do you
really know these candidates you're
pushing for
peel back a little bit on their
histories a little bit and look at what
some of the stuff they've stood for in
the past and maybe you wouldn't be so
aggressive
you know to me every time one
side is about to win all three the
opposing side says what's best for
america
is to not have one side have all three
right
but if the republicans have it their way
they'd love to have all three if
democrats have it their way they'd love
to have all three if it's up to the
politicians because
it's easier in those two years to get
what everything done tom
don't hold back with this one tom be the
time of biz doc
give us the energy of tom not the one
that's safe they're trying to be a
little too worried about what could
happen give us your brain we are relying
on your brain and processing
let me ask the question if everything's
won the democrats have senate
house and presidency what happens in two
years
in the first two years because it's not
going to be more than two years but what
can they get done in that two-year
period
i think either okay this is what i
let it go let's no no no we can go back
and see what what happens with history
clinton got that in his first term yeah
and he attempted to ram through
the first version the great great great
grandfather of obamacare he and hillary
he appointed hillary as first lady to
this
commission remember and they ran that
through and the mid-term elections
was one of the biggest hell no's in
american electorate history
as the midterms flipped to bring balance
back the other way
i i am conservative i i want to see
kelly loffler win because i think that's
the best chance
for the senate holding up conservative
business policy and tax policy that i
care deeply about
but i i really think that if they win
all of it
they're going to fumble the opportunity
for two reasons one there's a civil war
going on in the democratic party
aoc is pissed that she doesn't have a
cabinet post or someone close to her
on the squad that has some sort of a
cabinet post so the hard hard left is
very upset with the moderate left
somehow someway elizabeth warren is not
in the mix
you know it's a more moderate cabinet so
there is a and bernie
so bernie liz aoc in the squad there is
a civil war
on the democrat side pushing how real is
that how real is it i think it's
i think it's damn real is that just
articles being written on the right or
is that really happening
i think you look at the position of you
look at what aoc is saying and look at
the position of stuff i think you can
see it please
totally believe it totally they think
they can push through and they think
they're teflon
they literally do i mean they got voted
into the house you agree
i agree i agree i think they can't
believe anybody would be opposed
to them they want absolute power this
squad
and what they're looking for and they
can't understand any resistance to it
whatsoever it just doesn't
doesn't register for them so it will be
an awesome so let me ask you a question
so you asked me about midterms yeah and
i think
i think the pendulum will swing the
other way on midterms because
the wrong thing if i was running
strategy for biden i would say listen
the wrong thing would be too much too
soon
while these conservatives are still
triggered and activated midterms are
going to come quick
but i think they're going to go a little
too fast i think they're going to do a
little too much and i think it's going
to swing back the other way
i think biden at his heart is a little
bit old school i really do i don't think
he's buying into all this
i mean he did things a certain way for
40 years
he's used to back room deals you know in
the senate and he's been part of all of
this for the last
40 years he's not going to embrace all
this radical change right away i'm
hoping
i'm giving him the benefit of the doubt
right now but i'll disagree with you
guys on one thing
i think politicians number one
motivation is self-preservation
and i think if they felt they owned all
three
the house the senate and the president
that they knew there would be such
turmoil in two years half of them would
be gone
so i think there's some sort of benefit
some on the left that are saying it's
not
i think deep down i don't think they all
believe that it's the best scenario
for their party for themselves because
they can be swept away
even a long-term congressmen could be
you know
sent packing in the upheaval in two
years so i think that
most of them are thinking i just want to
stay here i want to clean
sail through my next election in two
years and just stay here so i think
that they'd be okay if if the democrats
didn't control the senate
so did biden come across now that this
is taking place now that's
already you know everything's going
through the way it is and the last thing
that's left is with you know pence you
know having to sign off and i think
pence is being sued right now
uh for possibly not being able to sign
off you know hold him back and you know
what things he could
he could do himself so biden's come
coming out now being way more moderate
than people thought he was going to be
is he more moderate than obama was
or is too too too soon to tell i think
it's too soon but i think he'll probably
be if obama's in eight i think he's
gonna be like a six and three-quarter
okay so he's not gonna be far left as
obama right and here's the other
difference between him and obama
obama had joe biden as vice president
who was pretty
passive joe biden has kamala harris who
is the opposite of joe biden as a vice
president
power hungry um she doesn't come for
that next move
and she doesn't come with a stable full
of relationships from all those years in
the senate joe biden brought that
yeah you know he may not have been
really valuable to obama at the voting
booth and he wasn't
but he was very valuable in terms of all
the relationships he had him all
all those years since i will say i'm
surprised he hasn't stuck one of these
squad members in some sort of
high-ranking cabinet position
to be honest with you i think a lot of
people are surprised what do you think
that says about him though i think a lot
of people
so so here's a question this becomes a
question for me so there's there's two
arguments here one is
is this biden's doing or
is it the people behind closed doors who
put up the money
saying listen here's what you're gonna
do you're gonna put this person you're
not even gonna get close to any of these
aoc
elizabeth warren guys you're going to
put the people that we recommend you to
put in
janet yellen is going to be fine some of
the things that's going to take a hit on
capital gains going to take place
some of the things that's going to
happen with taxes where it's going to go
you were talking about yesterday with me
from 33 to 39
that's going to take place but for the
most part is it biden's
strategy that's coming out saying here's
who i'm picking or is the money people
behind closed doors i think it's some of
the money that's keeping biden
kind of in the biden zone i think it's a
lot of that
you know the money remember money
doesn't like change money
and money hates radical change
i i think the words biden in strategy
are mutually exclusive i don't think he
has any strategy
not any big thinking he's the accidental
president i mean he got thrown into this
thing he shouldn't even won the primary
if you think about it and here he is as
the president at 78 years old so i think
it's behind
it's it's the group behind this is a
this is a you know a group effort a
conglomerate
behind him making decisions you agree i
i absolutely agree i think there's a
group that's that is strategically
trying to keep this
moderate and then keep control and move
agendas forward and
i don't think they're uh to be trifled
with because i think they want to move
left
but i think they want to keep it from
being you know
you know squad operation let's not let's
say he's not still capable of putting
complete buffoons in some of these
positions so let's see what they do
so so here's the question if you're
watching this if you're watching this
what is more likely to happen
if it's more likely to have republicans
win both seats and senate press thumbs
up
if it's more likely that the dems are
going gonna win the two seats in the
senate push thumbs down i'm actually
curious to know what you think about him
by the way
vote logically not emotionally thumbs up
if you think republicans can win both in
senate
logically if you think dems are going to
win both in senate put thumbs down but
i'm actually curious
to know what you guys think what do they
do if it's a split if they think it's
gonna be one and one
i don't wanna i just wanna see if they
think it's gonna be two two that's what
i'm curious about
the one it could end up being a one one
because i think that's where you are
you're more on the one one team
i think kelly loffler went by knows and
um
all right cool sounds good so let's talk
about nashville don't you tell us what's
going on with nashville
this is like very interesting what
happened there okay so christmas morning
right you hear about this explosion and
you know the first time you read the
story or hear about it
you know the first thing you think is
hopefully not anybody was killed and
nobody was i mean
it's a minor miracle that nobody
actually was killed in this so then they
say
stop right there yeah thumbs up and a
shout out to those six cops that
evacuated everything
and the the two very big cops at the end
that split to the end of the streets
and kept all the patrol cars back thumbs
up to them
all those first responders learnings
from everything in america and nobody
else got hurt praise god you know what
and we will never
hear the full story of the heroic
efforts of these cops
when they heard that recorded message on
this rv saying
if you hear this message evacuate if you
hear this message
they were knocking on doors saving lives
six cops and you know in the year of
defund the police the year
thankfully ends with us understanding
just how important they
are i mean this is such a joke anybody
that still believes
in the defund the police movement
especially when you see the murder rates
that have gone up minneapolis murder
rate is up 74 percent over last year
dallas is up dallas is up 34 shootings
insane how much they're up
i mean when you start peeling back and
look at the number of cops that are
taking early retirement man it's going
to scare you for what's going on in the
future but
kudos to those law enforcement officers
in nashville it was unbelievable so then
you start learning more about this nut
job right you
automatically assume what's this guy's
problem what's he trying to do yeah
today a story comes out that you know
now all the neighbors are gonna start
talking yesterday one of the neighbors
that talked to him at the mailbox said
oh yeah he i was gonna say that
everybody's gonna know my name in a few
days
today one of his old friends was saying
that he was a pot-smoking cop-hating
kind of oddball weirdo so he has to be
weird the other
interesting backstories about this guy
is he was sued by his own mother
over these two pieces of property that
he deeded
to this woman this 29 year old executive
in the entertainment industry she works
at
aeg in los angeles she now has two of
the houses
one of the which warner was living in
warner is the name of the suspect
so it blows up this entire street right
this rv
explodes and then you're thinking why
this street and then you know it's
it's looking like the target was this a
t building yeah
which was on that second street in in
nashville not just any building
and the right exact massive regional
switch center yes so you know
uh cell phone services down throughout
multiple states in the area including
nashville
the flooding you know from from this
explosion led to the the services being
outaged
but you know you're going to see some
other stories now maybe some conspiracy
theories or people that are you know
looking into this thing a little bit
deeper but
one of the things that that att control
operations
headquarter thing did there on 2nd
street was have something to do with
the compilation of the voting in georgia
all right so there is some sort of
connection between
a t in that building in nashville and
what's going on as far as tabulations
and
and data and things that are happening
regarding the election in georgia the
senate runoff so
um you know and then and then did you
hear that
you know later in the day they found
another van in tennessee that was
recording to say or playing this yeah we
type a recorded message but
they over have over 100 atf and fbi
agents on this thing we're going to
learn a lot more about this a lot
a lot uh you know sooner here but this
guy was an oddball
uh he apparently was paranoid about 5g
technology
so yep you know it only makes sense that
the a t
building was what he was going after tom
i i
i think this shows you kind of the dark
side
of passion you know there are you know
and
the riots we saw this summer was a dark
side of passion and
you know it it really disappoints me to
see what's happening in america
when you see people like this that are
just you know
stepping up and doing it it just kind of
flipped me out question becomes
can these events be prevented can these
events can this can boston can these
happen so
i don't think we want a nanny state but
i think that
you know there's a difference between
those uh the two guys in boston
remember one of them ran over his
brother and killed him in the shootout
remember let's just remember that
you know family family ties there baby
the i think what this is going to bring
up i'm going to be more aware of my
neighbors
and if i got a neighbor that's on the
friends it's not that i'm going to turn
them in it's like
wait what's going on here and i would
hope it leads to an america that's not
like a nanny state spying on your
neighbors but is aware of the people in
your life and is aware of things
and people can get help uh and i think
will prevent
you know some of things like this those
two guys in boston they were radicalized
students this was a like a hard plan
this guy seems like he was a lonely
weird kook over time
that took a horrible big step i think
tom question
question for you yeah question for you
guys okay so you remember that one movie
with tom
tom cruise that uh is arresting people
on future crimes what was the name of
the movie
uh minority report right do you think
we're ever gonna get to a point where
one can based on searches you're making
for example if i go on google
okay and i'm searching how to make a
bomb
and i go and do searches like that for
one day two days three days how to make
a bomb to explode a building how to make
a bomb
do you think there's any any day anytime
soon that we'll get to a point
where there's gonna be a trigger to have
somebody come in
you know see why is this guy searching
these kinds of what can be done for
people like this to be prevented can
this be prevented
100 percent i mean nashville is a
beautiful city man this is i lived there
for a couple years so
how can you prevent this stuff from i
mean think about it did we think a year
ago that if you tweet something out
that it could be censored okay so even
in this past
year we've seen where if you do
something online there's repercussions
right if you start talking about bombs
or radical groups or i hate
the fbi or things like that you would
think that they would
you know be able to intercept this
especially if you couple that with he
went down and bought 50 000 pounds of
fertilizer right i mean that's usually a
bad
mix to make a bomb but the fbi said this
guy wasn't even on their radar screen
they didn't even know about him
so you can have a lone wolf like this
who's tactical who's weird
who's crazy i want to see what's going
on with this 29 year old executive in la
i mean she already deleted all her
social media so
there's some sort of tie-in with her in
this quack from from nashville that blew
up second street but
it's sometimes just an infatuation for a
woman
can make you do stupid things well but
what i'm trying to
my question is more from a perspective
of you're big on technology
you're a fan of technology you're a
believer of technology we're talking
about earlier with aws doing 22 million
dollars and
q3 not 12 million dollars q 300 trillion
12 billion and q3 yeah and monster about
to
pass up some of these other guys which
we'll talk about here in a minute but do
you think
there will be a time where we will have
a technology that's going to say
be careful this guy is scoring in a 80
percentile that he's about to
dot dot dot where action can be taken to
prevent
behaviors like this do you think we'll
ever get to that point
we're in the baby stage of it right now
because the united states secret service
does this all the time
and they are they scan they have analyst
groups they have
they have a ton of technology that's
going out there looking at the
inflammatory statements and see if there
is
develops a person of interest to go
pre-interview secret service will knock
on your door and do an interview
um you can you know go look up you know
secret service
interviews secret service spot
interviews field interviews
there is a non-armed side of the
treasury department that was working on
counterfeiting and everything like that
of the treasury department
that is out there doing it so in a small
way it's happening now
where they're trying to be you use ai
and other things to say
should we knock on somebody's door and
go check them out before they do
something so in a small way it's
happening today
what what i think is the technology is
accelerating and i think it's
accelerating
and i think that you know what
if you're a little bit more of a
conspiracy theorist you know
you have all these anti-trust hearings
everybody's getting pulled except reid
hastings in front
google twitter facebook they all end up
in front of congress and these handy
trust hearings
those simple deals they'll be made right
i'll tell you what you know we're going
to
suspend this hearing but this is what we
need we need access to this we need
access to that
and the government will have access to
it and they'll have their own think
tanks and stuff so
i think we're seeing it starting today
and it's only getting bigger i think
you're right
i'm sure they're so far ahead of it
already and i have no problem with it
you know if you think that's an invasion
of the pr
of your uh privacy stop talking about
building bombs online then
i think if you're doing that and you
create that sort of red flag the
government should come knocking on your
door
and you know here's the next question
can they send a drone over you and take
you out
if you're a real big threat like we do
with terrorists you know around the
world
um but yes you went straight from like
progress to
freaking middle east you know permission
to take a guy out
tom you went all the way to the end so i
did
yes you did i kind of did fast forward
that a little bit would you be if you if
you're listening i mean we got a a
a one of the valentine's fish said thank
you for talking about this all the way
from nashville
uh uh tdog 419 gave five bucks and he
said presidential elections tend to have
greater democratic turnout
so the georgia runoffs will most likely
go to republicans
interesting presidential elections tend
to have greater democratic run of
turnout
so the georgia runoffs will most likely
go this is
419. interesting point on what he's
saying here
and then we had a couple others we had
jonathan ventura and if you want to eat
at the restaurant but feel like you
should be
social distance and with a mask there is
a spot in the restaurant one or two
tables
that are socially distanced jesse
ventura you may have given something
prior to that that is the only one that
i'm seeing here
but i'm curious how many of you that are
listening to this right now
would be comfortable if we were to get
to a point where technology is watching
people's behavior
online where it's not necessarily a
facebook watches you talk about the
furniture that you want to buy next
thing you know 70 furniture ads come up
you're like wait a minute
i didn't even touch my phone these ads
come up but this time around
you're having a conversation you're
sitting with somebody talking about i'd
love to
bomb this such and such place or blow
this place up
it leads to triggering a federally
funded organization that comes out to
want to investigate to see why did you
say that and why was that come
would you be comfortable with that if
you're listening to this would you be
comfortable with the government
because remember fbi was an idea why
don't we come up with the federal bureau
of investigation what is it here's what
it does
cia was an idea a lot of these
organizations are ideas
trump just came out with the new uh the
space uh what does he call it space
force
right something like that space force if
i would have told you 10 years ago space
force you would have thought it's a
hollywood movie but it's actually a real
thing
space force right would people come be
comfortable with us coming up with an
organization
that actually studies your behavior and
you could get arrested for potentially a
future crime you may commit
don't don't forget homeland security
right homeland security is brand new
yep brand new spooky november of uh 0-1
is when they came
up brand new and by the way if you want
to think about surveillance
that's the guys that would have all the
permissions
you know we're doing this to keep
america safe listen to the listen to
what they say about the virus right pat
we're doing this we're doing the
lockdown so you could be safe and people
buy into it
you know whoever oh no no we're doing
homeland security we're doing all these
things into your background so you could
be safe
would you be comfortable with that would
you be comfortable with what i just
asked kyle would you be okay with that
it's like minority report yeah would you
be okay with that you wouldn't be
no sam because because a part of the
power would be abused right
absolutely i always go too far sam
correct are you in the same place as
kyle are you also in the same
sometimes out of place yeah frustration
yeah and a mental
crime is not the same as a physical
crime well have you ever gone into a
fight with a middle eastern
you see the things they'll say i swear
to god say that again i'ma bomb this
place like
every middle eastern would be arrested
in glendale because when the fight
breaks out
they'll say i'm going to bomb this
restaurant and you know people would be
but that's a good point
by the way i'll take the opposite view i
got no problem with it you haven't no i
got no problem at all because i'll tell
you why
i got a better chance of getting blown
up by some psycho by getting killed
then i have you're totally cool i'm cool
with it because i'm not going to build a
bomb
i'm not going to talk about it on social
media so i want the idiots that are
going to do it to be investigated you
know who else should be investigated
the neighbors that come out the next day
and say oh he seemed normal
oh he was such a nice guy investigate
them because they're stupid
if they can't see some of these clues
that this this
jerk down the block or on the cul-de-sac
has an rv and there's a ticking noise
coming out of it for the last three
weeks
that's insane by the way a lot of people
are commenting saying i don't trust the
government with dictating morality and
speech
edward snowden told you this already
it's already happening pat
will it pick it up if it says something
mind-blowing no because they would abuse
it just like the patriot act it's got a
good point homeland security is scary
enough
that's a big time tyranny says dutch
and we had mohammed karma in cameron
said palantirs already
has the minority report tech it's called
gotham and they are using it right now
we talked about palantir before
and how all of a sudden they became a 20
billion dollar company and no one knows
who volunteer is
so it's already in the works but uh it
doesn't
it's like a mix i think 90 doesn't want
it 10 percent wants it one person cannot
wait for it
and that's tom zender's community so he
is looking
forward to that
okay so tom elon musk sends a tweet out
and
somebody asked him david lee on december
24th ask him a question
says personally i think elon musk is the
best investor of capital
and innovator at scale in our generation
that might be an understatement
kyle if you have that tweet if you can
pull it up that might be an
understatement this is an opportunity to
create a structure
that would optimize his time and
interest
the most right and then elon musk
responds in engineering
design and general company operations
observe vast majority of my mind and are
the fundamental limitation
on doing more capital allocation is
important but low cpu load
tesla publicly public company duties are
much bigger factor but
going private is impossible
now parentheses side
okay yes psy now
while you're looking at this tweet with
what he says what it does the tesla
stock tom is going to give us an update
on that here's what ends up happening
gm's 27 billion electric electrical bet
begins with bad boy hummer truck the
giant automaker plans to push out 30
electric vehicles by 2025
to take on market leader tesla inc
starting with the two most iconic brands
at the top of its roster cadillac and
hummer
gm is spending 27 billion dollars in an
all-out effort to remake
40 of his lineup and re-tool one-third
of its us vehicle assembly factories
putting it in a one-way path to
electrification tesla's aggressively
building more production
around the globe the president elect joe
biden and other political leaders
elsewhere pushing more ev-friendly
government policies
that will help plug-ins as uh sell like
tesla ceo elon musk bera has an
advantage over rivals such as ford motor
company volkswagen ag
plentiful supplies of its own batteries
co-developer would partner lg to
chem ltd the much ball anyways this is
going to talk about who can potentially
compete
gm is also boosting that truck will go
450 miles
before needing hr tom what what
happened when elon musk sent this tweet
out on christmas eve
well the stock went up because
everybody's like oh he's never going to
take it private
so it was kind of the opposite of that
thing yeah ready to go private
funding secured and the security
exchange commission said all right buddy
pull over
license and registration please you know
and
what nuts what i think people forget is
he is still the leader in ev
monstrous leader in ev you know he has
80 markets here in the united states all
these great big articles about gm and
everything gm is a very capable company
they're giving up
cadillac and hummer high-end cars that
are very expensive there she is
that's mary barrett what she was saying
right there is dear god please make my
stock grow up when i say the word
electric
dear god please make my stomach did it
help him uh no no it was
kind of like a rosary she just kept
repeating and it didn't really help at
all she stuck at 60 billion in market
share
which um they sold about eight it was an
interesting stat they sold like eight
million cars
this year approximately and at 60
billion dollar market cap that's about 7
500 bucks a car so
you got to say that one more time so
they sold 8 million
cars in 2020 correct and then market cap
is 60 billion correct okay so it's about
7 500 per car if you just use that as a
measure
and if you contrast that with tesla
which is 60
600 600 billion dollar market cap
and they sold about 435 000 cars this
year um it wasn't for pandemic they
would have touched half a million cars
this year
so that's 1.4 million dollars per car
sold
so in terms of future value and what
people think
elon musk is two universes ahead
but gm's gonna catch up they're gonna
catch up and figure it out
and you know the model s is old it's
eight years old but it's nice
so elon musk is about to be in a more
com gonna go from the leader status
to a guy that's got other sharks in the
same pool with him
but i i don't bet against him but this
feels a little bit to me
like the empire strikes back like here
comes the second chapter of the movie
is what i feel like is coming you know
gm only sold 110
000 cars this year that's 1.4 yet this
is their website
and you look up there gm's path to an
all-electric future
never mind 98.6 of our cars still use
dead dinosaurs
so it's is this fear is this strategy is
this
a urgency is this the right strategy
what what would you say about this i i
think it is
i think it's fear and urgency right now
and i think they're trying to move their
their stock and they're trying to get
out in front of it i do think it's fear
in urgency right now
because tesla you know is ahead but the
one that i would fear if i was elon musk
not fear but keep an eye on
is gm because of the battery supply
chain because right now the battery
pack of the car is still more expensive
than the internal combustion engine
still more expensive interesting
those lines will cross we know they
cross
with with volume today you know led
lights
very environmental and everything and
nice light in your house use a lot less
energy
you can go buy a pack of 10 for about 40
bucks
at home depot now you just go back eight
nine years ago
a single led light bulb was like 50
bucks
and now you're buying them in super pacs
the same thing's kind of the batteries
and when those lines cross
people like gm are going to get volume
on their side
and push so he's got to put out new cars
he's got to keep driving
tom let me see let me give the math one
more time what you just said this is
very important i don't know if you guys
caught this or not did you guys catch
what the matthew gave or
okay so here's pay very close attention
to what tom just said
gm sold 8 million cars
8 million cars not eight hundred
thousand
cars eight million cars and their market
cap is 60 billion dollars if you take
60 billion you divide it by 8 million
tom's getting 7 500 uh dollars they're
making
this year right this year now and now if
you take
is it eight is 7 500 or 75 000 times is
it 7 500 75. if you take
tesla's market cap 600 billion but they
only sold 435.
so gm sold 8 million cars they're worth
60 billion
tesla soared 435 000 cars there were 10
times
more but they sold 20 times less cars
and if you break down the 600 billion uh
by how many cars they sold the average
car they sell is 1.4 million dollar
profit to them
you gotta understand how this market is
right now saying what tesla's worth
so here's what i read about an article
tom wrote i said on vtpose.com
wells fargo is saying tesla
is about to be the next aol in 2021.
this is wells fargo
wells fargo is not a smaller company
wells fargo says
tesla's about to be the next aol so
either the market
is infatuated with the ceo and they're
making the value of this company go to
where it's at today
or tesla's about to be the aol which one
is right
well he is a rock star okay and that
is a big big part of it and you know
what i think a lot of attention gets
placed on this because we're so sick of
the negativity all the other news the
coronavirus
you know uh the the warring factions
between the democrats and the
republicans i think some of this
he gets so much publicity can he be
oversaturated pretty soon i mean
is can he be overexposed sometimes i
think there's almost too much elon musk
but the guy is so brilliant and he keeps
delivering
i will say this i've never been an
electro electric car guy
you know and i'm not really a car person
but you know what yesterday have you
ever owned one or no why not okay but i
live in california which is the home of
it where everybody has one so yesterday
i
i have a diesel suv and there's one gas
station i can go to where
in california it's 3.33 cents per gallon
as opposed to 3.63 cents a gallon so i
drive there and yesterday i'm thinking i
just spent
25 minutes of my day going out of my way
to this gas station
so i could save 30 cents on completely
overpriced gas
the way it is i want to get an electric
car i went to the mall because i had to
you know one day over the holidays all
the good parking spots are electric
they literally build the infrastructure
of parking lots right now
for you to charge your car office
buildings where my office is in la
i mean you want the best primo spot it's
where the electric hookups are
and you know what i'm in and i think
this is the next arms race
i mean that's why apple's involved this
thing is going to get crazy because the
whole world
is going to want and need an electric
car and i'll make one last point you
know who should go into the electric car
business
not saying it's easy but should exxon
right why can't they spend you know 500
billion in
in research and development and come up
with their own because they're not going
to sell any gas
that would be hilarious if exxon went
into the car business
okay i have been holding my tongue for a
minute but
for wells far i have no love for wells
fargo wells fargo was the nice bank that
opened extra
credit cards and extra accounts for you
without telling you about it
suffered a huge federal and they lost
their ceo and
your criminal charges were filed so i i
think that there's a bit
of um you know overreaction there is
does tesla kind of come back to earth a
little bit on this valuation over time
sure they are but i don't bet against
the entrepreneur and the
and pardon the expression the engine
that is in elon musk's heart
he's not just going to sit by and let it
happen we're going to see
you know remember we thought that the
that the lineup of cars was getting
boring
and and elon musk kept saying boy you
know our car's getting kind of boring we
got to do design things he was saying
that for three weeks remember that
remember what he did
he goes on stage with this incredible
weird truck
announcing the tesla truck and it's like
oh okay
the super truck and i'm moving to austin
so he knows what he's doing he's got a
whole
funnel of things to do what it was one
thing i would say
is what you're talking about moving over
to energy you know
i saw a list of the plug-in
infrastructure players and the number
two ranked on
number of new parking spots installed is
bp
british petroleum correct yeah yeah so
one so this part of my arm from my elbow
to my fingertips is doing electric
the rest of my body bp is still selling
diesel natural gas and stuff
what was interesting you and i both know
a guy uh ev connect in los
angeles jordan ramer we were in a ceo
council together remember
jordan raymore ev connect he is he was
out there
making um infrastructure as an
entrepreneur out there
becoming a reseller of energy and
building the infrastructure
so that a mall could put in the parking
spaces and he was trying to convince
people
don't just make it a benefit for the top
three spots
because the first spots were for
handicapped and then we have pregnant
mothers
socially really good ideas to do that
and then we put the evs up there now
wait a minute there's nothing wrong with
someone driving an ev
but they get to be closer and jordan
riemer went out there with this dream he
just said
hey i think we should build entire parts
of parking lots and everything
and so i think there's a lot of
entrepreneurship going on there that
it's only gonna
it's only gonna help but i'm not betting
against um
i'm not betting against elon musk pat
i'll make this comment and i'll be
interested to see your uh reaction to it
i think some of elon's competitors see a
vulnerability with him
and here's what it is he runs two other
businesses he has spacex
he has that boring company that's
building the tunnels in la and vegas and
everything
and he moved to austin so his companies
are in out in california
and he's over here do you do you think
he's minimized by the fact that he's the
ceo of these
huge huge globally changing companies
something's going to suffer and i would
imagine a smart guy like a tim cook
and the people at gm and their
competitors are thinking you know
there's part of his day every day he's
not devoting to tesla
and does he have enough of a army behind
him
to make up for he's the man running the
show so years ago
i mean ilan i think he's got four or
five kids he's got he's got a good
amount of kids i don't know the exact
number where he's got four or five kids
and i think he wrote about it in an
article written by neil strauss
a very lengthy article great article
written about him when they were doing
an interview
and one of the reasons why he decided to
you know go be single is he wanted to
marry his career now he does his best to
be a father but he doesn't want to have
any kind of full commitments he
definitely wants to be in relationships
and not but he wants to be able to
commit
to his businesses his babies are the
companies he runs
he treats his companies like his babies
that's that's where he's at i remember
one time i sat down
with uh former cfo of aig okay and him
and i were having dinner where you know
you weren't there we were in ritz
carlton chicago
and he's sitting right next to me and
this is when they went and got the money
from the government 183 billion dollars
and i said so you know tell me about
yourself you know he says well you know
i do this i said how many kids you got
he said i don't have any kids really
you're not married so no i'm married
how long guys been married we've been
married for 25 plus years how come you
don't have any kids
my wife and i made a decision a long
time ago that our babies was going to be
our career
we were going to dedicate that energy
into our
career not kids and we felt kids were
going to take away time away from
our career now think about you have kids
you have kids yep i have kids i got an
eight seven and a four and one underway
right
you got dash and ivanka you got brooke
and bailey right
how many total hours has been put into
his kids
actually think about it i want you to
actually think about it
how old is bailey how old is brooke how
many total hours of your time
have you put into your babies
don't don't say i would not replace it
i'm not talking about that
i'm just asking you think about yes how
many of your life
hours was put into your kids diapers
park picking them up dropping them off
talking to them
sitting down everything's gonna okay how
many hours
it's in you can't even count them plus i
have a daughter named brooke as well
she's just graduated from pepper that's
how pepper died yeah she grew up in the
bay area all the time i flew back and
forth
how many hours it's actually i think i
want you to think about it
i'm trying to think about it if you were
to think about it put the hours what do
you think that hours is for you
is it in the tens of thousands yes is it
in the is it in the thousands
okay so if you have those tens of
thousands of hours
that you put into your kids to put into
something else how would they do
so you have to understand the fact that
that that the part about putting time
into his babies i think he's got plenty
of time
all right i don't think that's a
challenge for him to do now as far as
him being exploited and can they get to
him and all this other stuff
you know when when you're going into the
nba there's a couple different kind of
players you go into major league
baseball or nba there's a couple
different kind of players there's
players that
want to play with who michael because
they're enamored by it
like you know how they when jordan came
back and he went to the wizards
the bench could never play he says my
teammates wouldn't play because they
would just stand there not play defense
and rotate
because they were watching michael
they're like oh my gosh i'm enamored by
my play the damn basketball game right
but there were also guys like kobe
coming up saying dude i'm not scared of
you
you know i'm coming for you there's
going to be people that are going to
want to compete with elon
that's just that's just you know true
but wanting to compete with him
and maybe not being that next level
thinker and genius that he is you're
already starting behind the eight
you are but there's gonna be somebody
the market tells us there's always
somebody that comes out
that wants to do something it's just
it's always been like i also think tesla
has to stay cool
i'm not excited about a gm electric car
now i am excited about the hummer that
you had mentioned
that they're going to come out with the
new hummer that's going to be electric
why don't you talk about what they're
planning on doing with cadillac by 2025
this is a pretty strong statement made
about cadillac and i think it's a smart
statement
and it comes out of this fact here's the
simple fact for you
if you take away the federal subsidies
and the discounts that are paid for our
government on the
cars tesla is not cash flow positive on
each car
think about that even at half a million
cars a year they're not
cash flow positive so we need these
federal subsidies
green air subsidies so that you can do
this
that's number one very important gm
knows this
and gm knows that because of batteries
the cars are going to be expensive for a
while
so i think gm made one really very
good strategic move in maribera's
announcement um where she was saying
please god make my stock go up and that
is they're sacrificing
cadillac as a gas brand cadillac is
going to be an electric brand
it's more expensive there's a higher
price point
there's more features that are inside so
they're going to do that
so that the brand and its cost lines up
with the underlying more expensive cost
to make an electric car i think that's
smart i think that's smart and they're
saying hey by 2025
hummer is a cool announcement cadillac
is more of a consumer point of
tesla-esque move some volume people who
are willing to pay 80 grand to 100 grand
for a catalog
now for a gm so for every hummer you
sell you'll probably sell five of those
little cx i can see that i can totally
see that
i can totally still let me let me give a
quick shout out to a couple guys here
that gave a few dollars and put comments
here
uh paul nieto iii said the same thing he
said i think the biggest company
elon owns will be neural link
if the tech can really work and take off
interesting to say neural link he thinks
will be the biggest company he runs
uh uh paul you didn't get a big reaction
from these guys so maybe they're wrong
or maybe you're wrong but maybe
somebody's right by the way croatia just
had a big earthquake a couple hours ago
i don't know if you guys heard about
crosstalk
6.2 earthquake that took place it's
pretty ugly if you type in croatia
earthquake
you'll see what happened i mean it's
it's i'm getting messages here
uh uh ivan x uh underscore ciara says i
know you like croatia i don't like
croatia i love croatia
did you see news about the six point two
earthquake that hit about three hours
ago i lived 60 miles away from the
epicenter
and my christmas tree fell down wow yeah
so this is uh yeah if you look at this
one here it is
that's no joke no it is no joke
especially when the infrastructure
isn't as solid we had a flat rate
inspection shout out to gene
gene chapman of php give me a great two
and a half million dollar index policy
great company family like
i recommend all my youth to look into
benefits of index life great
shout out to gene chapman great job gene
and then we have
more that's coming in here from this so
let's get back into it so now this leads
me
into what tim cook said okay tim cook
goes out there and uses one word in his
speech
one word in a speech that made apple 103
billion dollars
by just dropping one word kyle do you
want to
bring up that picture so tim cook gets
up there
and says we may
come out with a apple car
they have not sold a single car but they
made 103 billion dollars
without having sold a single car do you
think apple can compete
in the car market i don't think so
in terms of manufacturing and going
through all that headache but i think
that the apple
experience i think if apple went
to someone like a ford and says hey
you build it but it's the apple
experience and and it's all that
great connection between hardware and
software because remember the apple
phone unlike android
the apple phone they control the
hardware and the software and they make
it work together so beautifully
i think if they do that with one of the
big manufacturers
i think it's a player i think it's very
very real i'll have to disagree with tom
here
i think if they i think if they decide
they want to get into the cars they're
going to do it and they're going to do
it very well
they have a couple advantages i mean
it's the same analogy with the phone if
someone said hey do you think they could
have a great phone down the road and
who knew that they were already working
on it for five years they have the
ability to go hire anybody they want why
can't they go get the best people at
tesla
the very very best in the world get them
and steal the secrets and
and just do it a little bit better plus
you automatically coming out of the gate
thinking that whatever apple designs is
going to be cutting edge
different cool out of the box gotta have
it
you know latest bells and whistles the
whole thing so man i think they're right
there
now they might be a little aggressive
with 2024 you know maybe that's a little
bit
sooner than realistically being able to
roll these off the assembly line but
man i'm kind of excited to think what
they can do making cars i think it's
gonna be spectacular
here's what elon musk said about it on
december 22nd during the darkest days of
the model 3 program i reached out to tim
cook
to discuss the possibility of apple
acquiring tesla
for one-tenth of our current value which
means around 60 billion
okay give or take he refused to take the
meeting
strange if true tesla already uses iron
phosphate for medium-range cars made in
shanghai factory a
a monocellus electron electrochemically
impossible as
max voltage is a hundred times too low
maybe they meant
cells bonded together like our
structural battery pack
so i don't know whether that was a shot
being taken or not but if he's
responding to it
there's only one reason you would
respond if you actually think apple
could be
a threat if you respond right now you
know for me
by the way i'll read you what they said
in the reports here a closely watched
apple analyst is warning that investors
should be cautious about a report that
an iphone maker
is planning to produce a self-driving
car in 2024 last week's report by
reuters
sent shares of companies that built
parts of an uh autonomous
uh uh uh cars like litter centers
how do you pronounce that word l-i-d-a-r
lidar lidar centers sensors
soaring but but the hype was purely on
speculation some of those companies
might supply parts of the apple car tfi
analyst
ming chi kuo warned in a note this
weekend we believe that the current
so-called apple car concept stocks are
only speculations by the market and do
not involve
apple actual apple car suppliers
we also think that because ev
self-driving car technical specs are
still evolving
it is too early to talk about the final
specs of the apple car
the part of this conversation has taken
place is that
tim wants to have one big bang before
leaving
like he's getting to a point where he's
he's thinking about you know maybe
i've done my part my season's coming to
an end and i want to kind of leave with
a splash and it's
i come out with the apple car like i
would love to see
elon i had this conversation the other
day with um uh uh
uh mkbhd youtube channel 30 million
subscribers phenomenal conversation with
them
and i said what do you think are the
chances of tesla
elon musk going into the phone business
and winning
so question for both of you guys here
what's more likely to be successful
for elon musk to say screw you tim cook
i'm going to go into the phone business
and take market share away from you and
i'm going to create a tesla phone
is elon musk more capable of competing
in the phone business
and smartphone or is apple more capable
of competing in the car business what do
you think
apple's more capable of completing the
car business
absolutely you know if elon puts his
head to it he can battery
remember he can say battery this iphone
this computer a phone that i created
tesla the battery life lasts a week
true true i'm looking at the
entanglements off on the phone i
i the phone is like seven subsystems
batteries only one of them
you know you there are so many things
that go into a phone as well as the
community
and the whole application development
environment that took three years
just to develop that it is so much
easier
for apple to take experiential
programming and usage
and brand and put it around and you know
i think it's far easier for apple to
make a car with the right partner than
it's gonna be for elon musk to
make a phone complete opposite i think
it'd be way easier for elon musk to do a
tesla phone because he's already proven
he can do a tesla tequila
and anything else he wants to the other
thing too is drinking
and driving he'd be able to hurt apple
quicker
well that's a good idea drinking and
driving because it's a self-driving car
and you can drink and use the holder for
it yes but you were saying no no
when you drink give your car the keys
yeah i really think no
if he wanted to i mean look he's
building a tunnel to lax from hawthorne
i mean good god
and that gets no publicity or what he's
doing in vegas the guy can do anything
he wants
and set his mind to it plus he could be
a little nat nipping at apple and
stealing you know five percent of their
phone share which make a huge difference
to them
and it's easy i think you could produce
a phone quicker so yeah i think he could
do that by the way i am so against
self-driving cars i don't want to know
that the car next to me on the 405
is self-driving really tell me why
because it just scares me i i don't
trust self-driving cars at all
do you trust self-driving planes
self-flying yes but there's less traffic
in the air
[Laughter]
the less traffic in the air and you know
what there's not idiot
pilots next to him you know flanking him
all over
making illegal turns in front of him but
yes i do trust
sell flying planes more than i trust
pilots to be honest with you but the
self-driving cars i cannot wrap my arms
around it i know people that go to work
without
basically driving it's all programmed
what about if you have road rage is that
programmed into it where the car will
actually flip the other guy
hit the guy so so you're saying apple
is more likely to get into the car
business and succeed then elon musk
is likely to get into the phone business
and succeed yeah other tom makes good
points but i'm
i'm sticking with my point here's the
other thing musk is petty he'd do it
i know he would do it i know he would do
it yeah um
succeed keyword is succeed not just get
into it
it's to succeed who do you bet on i
think making a phone
just seems easier than making a car all
the parts so you think
tesla more than apple think so
unfortunately i have to go to
with tesla so tesla would have a better
shot you're thinking tesla or apple i'm
kind of rooting for tesla but i think
apple has a really good shot strictly
because growing up i always wondered you
know what if apple came out with their
own tv what if apple came out with their
own car
no one really thinks what if tesla came
out with their own can you imagine like
you drive an apple car
apple car you know what do you have the
latest apple car
you got it that car has got to look
pretty cool it's got to look different
it's got to be
they're not going to make a product that
doesn't look right you might get a free
laptop with it too
yeah i'm actually being though i like
your point too of that tim cook
might want to have some sort of legacy
play here because if he retires what's
he going to be known for
he developed a great stock price for
apple yeah there's nothing sexy about
his legacy
and then he bought a few companies right
and not to say that he's on steve jobs
level
but you still want to be remembered for
something especially when competing
against car
if he does the car and the car does
stuff it's it's
uh it's going to be interesting for
those of you guys that are watching this
what do you think is more likelihood of
happening elon musk competing in a
marketplace with phones or
tim cook and apple competing in the
marketplace with cars by the way another
question for you
right now tesla's worth worth what 600
billion dollars
do you think tesla in 2021 will cross a
trillion
i think it's yes i think it's maybe it's
not 21
or maybe it's early 22 but i think they
will be the next one in the tea club
so you're putting them to cross it so
you're saying wells fargo has no clue
what the hell they're talking about
i'm i'm not going to
debate the wells fargo article i'm
looking at where
elon musk is going with energy people
forget that tesla is at its heart not on
automotive
energy wells fargo article is important
they're saying tesla's the next aol
you're saying tesla's going to be the
next trillion dollar that is an argument
so do you think tesla you think wells
fargo is way off
with their assessment of tesla way off
okay so you think they'll be a trillion
dollar company uh
not in 2021 okay but i think they
eventually will be and have we ruled out
the fact that
dude have we ruled out the fact that he
could go the route of alphabet like
google has and put everything under one
umbrella is that impossible
i think if he does that he will he
probably won't do that because he knows
a biden
administration will try to break it
apart okay so he's going to be better
off just separating all of them so he
doesn't have to deal with the politics
do you agree with that tomorrow
he wouldn't put everything under one
company i i completely agree with that
right now
with the attitude in washington i think
any smart ceo is going to say hang on
let's
were you going to say more or death no
i think it's like let's have some more
stuff
hey by the way pat i mentioned this
earlier did you know that elon musk flew
to hawaii to go meet with larry ellison
what is that all about i don't know
there's got to be some strategic thing
behind it
no i'll tell you but if i was going to
go get advice and regulated and
if i thought i was in trouble i thought
i needed strategic advice on a macro
scale
i go talk to larry ellison you know
oracle and larry ellison
they are the lord god king of
lobbying against their competitors and
working with the senate and congress for
legislation
that helps oracle and doesn't help other
people so if i was going to go
get advice or work with people or look
at um
you know look at financing larry
everybody forgets
yeah what number is larry ellison he's
right up there 20 something
in the teens how about how about number
four or five or six
larry ellison is usually top ten four
five or six i like the way you're
thinking because your my first thought
was
who hates apple does larry ellison hate
apple is it but not really i mean there
isn't
this direct competitive thing there so
maybe the lobbying issue
where he stays a step ahead of it three
four five years down the road
tapping into some of that expertise that
he might have elon musk is not dumb and
larry ellison would be a great
private mentor and when i mean private
mentor i mean talking about things at
nine levels up you know what i mean plus
he could probably sell them a lot of
tequila i mean you gotta run up that
american party
elon musk tweets out saying just
meeting with larry ellison to seek some
advice back working on tesla end of
quarter tomorrow
december 28 2020.
he tweets that out i mean you got to
realize he's
sending a message to somebody hey that
tweet is probably only for one person
and no one knows who that one person is
okay you know pat at vtpost.com you know
you can kind of get a good gauge on
what what's driving the world what
people are interested in there isn't a
day
that goes by where i'm not picking an
elon musk story he's relevant every
single day
with something he does or at least
interesting he's at least
interesting and if you're gonna go visit
larry ellison the nice thing about
hawaii you can say larry i'm going to
bring my
pr person my security detail my entire
family do you have space
you know it's like i own the island of
lanai great so you have space
so you can have private conversations
with larry and there's just a lot of
space except for the two percent you
said right yeah two percent he owns 98
not but there's two percent
state apparently it's emergency services
and basic
you know what he paid for it do you know
the number what he paid for it was it
was pretty it was like 100 million it
wasn't much
i thought i thought it was 700 i thought
it was well it was like it was less
yeah what was it it's nothing it's less
than you would think for on hawaiian
island you know who else bought a ton of
property out there
isn't it zuckerberg wasn't he buying a
ton in hawaii too well
he bought a plantation for himself out
there
and that's a little south of island but
um it's uh
it's something yeah okay so stimulus
bill let's talk about the stimulus bill
apparently it uh
finally uh got through uh trump has
signed
into law a new 900 billion dollar
coronavirus relief and stimulus package
among its provisions
an extension of last spring's paycheck
protection program allowing another 284
billion
or so unforgivable federally backed
loans for ailing
small businesses the initial program
overseen by the us government treasury
and small business administration
shepherds some 255 billion dollars to
more than 5 million recipients but was
fraught
with loopholes and liabilities that
raised countless issues throughout an
already complex
uh process and then at the same time for
unemployment the coveted portion of the
bill revives a weekly pandemic jobless
benefit boost this time 300 through
march 14 it also extends
eviction protections adding a new rental
assistant fund
trump signing into this bill is two
thousand dollars plus the fact that
trump signed the stimulus into a
lawmaker
take uh pressure off of republicans in
both the house and the senate to vote
for the boosted checks allowing them to
stick to their guns
on keeping the size of the relief
package under control the government is
now funded
for the next year crucial benefits
helping americans through the pandemic
are renewed and 600
checks will be on its way if the two
thousand dollar checks don't
pass thoughts um first of all i'm glad
they closed the loopholes i saw a thing
in here that they have a uh
a loss test so your business can't apply
for scoop number two unless you can show
that you had a
greater than 25 percent you know quarter
over quarter drop as regarded
the pandemic i think that's a good thing
because i agree
there were some businesses out there
that just ran and got the money yes we
read about sports teams that really got
the money
four and a half million right harvard
business school got harvard got eight
and a half million dollars
and meanwhile but the lakers gave the
money back by the way like once and
that's where it came out
but meanwhile those small restaurants
and dry cleaners and people that are in
the neighborhood around staples center
downtown
you know we're having a hard time
getting five grand and the lakers did
but
lakers gave it back so when the
spotlight got shined they gave it back
but i like the fact that there's more
tests in now and it appears that this is
more friendly for the small business guy
to get in if you really had a loss and
it looks like it's harder
for the medium and large businesses just
to go fill out the form and get some
free capital
i like that part just when you didn't
think things could get any weirder you
have donald trump agreeing with
democrats
right pumping up the check value from
600 to 2000. this whole thing has been
bizarre
the senate still has to confirm this
thing right and they're they're ready to
break for the new year here pretty soon
but
good old bernie sanders is there a
bigger eagle maniac on the planet right
now than bernie sanders
i mean this guy's ego is so far but he's
got to be up there
it's up there here's what he said today
i will shut down the senate
i will force people to stay through who
are you you are one person from an
irrelevant state number one new
hampshire
basically irrelevant i mean who knows
anything about new hampshire
but he's out there saying he's going to
keep the city or vermont which looks
but you probably got it from you're
probably going to be i used to live in
new england that's a that's a big
mistake
all the small states look alike but you
know i'm in favor of anything that's
going to help the economy i'm in favor
of anything that's going to help small
businesses
if this also just shines a microscope on
what's going on in dc this bill was 6
000 pages long
who has a chance to actually read 6 000
pages of this legislation
all the pork that they try to jam in
this this thing is disgusting
but if it helps businesses if it helps
americans if it helps the economy i am
behind it i like the fact that trump
fought for a little bit more money
because 600 bucks really isn't that much
if you're gonna if you're gonna like
sign off on a bill of this magnitude
have a little bit more money going to
american citizens i think it's all is
okay
uh and i just hope there's less fraud
because when that first bill came out
there was so much fraud so many people
taking advantage of it i hope that they
found a way to shut that down
what is this going to do to the economy
i'll leave it up to you to answer that
one what is it going to do
it's going to give people a little bit
more confidence maybe hope maybe having
a little
thought that they can pay some more
bills maybe inject more money into the
economy i would imagine it will have
some sort of short
short-term effect yeah i think it's
going to be a little left going into
first quarter
absolutely i think january we're going
to see some you know
those little stats that come out cost
goes up a little bit
i i think the average joe that is able
to get a check is
going to be able to do a little bit and
i think it's going to be a little
short-term pop i think the the wall
street reaction will be greater
than the real impact on the average guy
the wall street rio
tell me what you mean by that i think
the market will be up more
than the actual change and the and the
lift and the help that we gave to the
average citizen
got it so the rich will get richer than
the poor will get a little richer
you're saying the rich is going to get
benefit from this more than the poorest
uh yeah absolutely or the ownership
class that's owning
can you unpack that why is that well
because the market's going to react and
the value of the assets are going to go
up for the people that already own those
assets
and don't and you know and make more
money and didn't need that extra
thousand dollars and we're ineligible to
it and the little guy on the corner
is going to get a thousand dollars it's
going to be thanks that helps me a
little bit meanwhile he's got another
eight thousand dollar in credit card
debt and everything he's gone through
you know it's you know that's the part
that this that kind of
fries me a little bit is we we never do
enough for
the citizen that's down at the end of it
and pete in my opinion
paycheck protection completely missed it
what you know paycheck protection should
meant if you prove you have no layoffs
and you prove what your
payroll is we'll pay x for a given
amount of time
and they did that weird thing where they
would give you some and then maybe we
forgive it maybe we don't forgive it
and it just seemed like that the little
guy didn't get enough so my opinion is
did they do better this time yeah but
i'm not cheering about it i think the
little guy still needs a little more
help
who wins here democrats or republicans
probably the democrats will spin it in a
way that they got trump to
you know come over on their side a
little bit more i don't know if i don't
look at this
and see that there's one clear winner
okay i think if you took a poll in the
street
the average the election's over except
georgia but the average person on the
street
i don't think is going to give a passing
grade to his government on this
does this regardless of how they voted
so right now is it fair to say that the
main thing that matters right now when
it comes down to politics is one state
11 million people right
george has done that does this influence
anything there like is this something
where trump's going to go and say
republicans got the deal done this is
why
and the democrats wanted to only give
600 and send the other money to
all these special interest groups and
other countries and we got it done to
get the money in the american people
you think that's going to create some
motivation for people to say
you know what republicans got this done
this is the last weekend
you're going to see those comments and
more there's going to be all kinds of
those claims
pat i think you're on it you're going to
see all kinds of those claims made in
the last weekend
we're not going to see them in the rest
of the u.s but on tv radio
the the georgia voters going to get
bombed by people taking credit and
spending that
i don't think anybody's vote could be
swayed by that at this point in georgia
and i wish maybe 20 billion of this
this bill would go into making sure
there's no fraud in the election that
there's people looking at every one of
these votes
making sure that they're checking the
signatures and making sure that whatever
happens in georgia on january 5th is
legit
i mean i think that's what everybody
wants to see i think people want to see
that taking place
in georgia okay so let's talk about a
little china you know since china's are
you know one of our favorite topics to
go through chinese journalist
who documented wuhan coronavirus
outbreak jail for four years
zhang john 37 years old was found guilty
of picking corals and provoking
trouble according to one of her defense
lawyers jan kiki
who attended her hearing the offenses
commonly used by the chinese government
to target dissidents
and human rights activists a former
lawyer zhang traveled
some 400 miles from shanghai to one in
early february to report on the pandemic
and subsequent attempt to contain it
just as authorities began reigning in
state and private chinese media for more
than three months she documented
snippets of her life
under lockdown and wuhan and the harsh
reality faced by the residents
from overflowing hospitals to empty
shops she posted her observations photos
on video on which
wechat twitter and youtube the latter
two of which are blocked in
china and she's now going to jail for
four years
thoughts scary i mean my god i don't
know
uh four years what she did
you know it's not like she was writing
editorials every day railing against the
president or railing against communism
she was basically documenting life
in china during the pandemic and then
you know the thing that just is crazy
about this is these charges i mean it
almost seems
like too bizarre like you couldn't even
make it up quarreling
you know things like that they can
literally almost invent a charge
to suppress people to lock them up to
show that they're in charge here
uh she's one of at least 47 journalists
that are in detention in china right now
so it's not like she's the only one
and you know what they get these people
and they're forgotten i mean who knows
what they're doing to them behind the
scenes before they even put them in
prison
so it's pretty scary um you know that
they can control
every bit of information that's said
about it and just
i think the other interesting thing is
to watch how the american media treats
this story
like if they're not appalled by it
there's something wrong
well i think the u.s media is is going
to it's going to talk about this but
then kind of give it a little bit of a
pass
because the corporate tentacles go all
the way
from from here to china let's face it
there's another word for china it's
called factory
and if you want to change the cost
structure of everything you buy from
this pen to the iphone
to the seats in your car um
get ready so a whole economic case study
i could drop into there but this
does not surprise me china
this is you don't you don't disagree
with big poppy that's it and
and it's not surprising and i think
you're like oh you got very strong
opinions today you got to hold back a
little bit with your opinions you you're
going a little too strong today and i
think you're offending people
you know i would like you to taper down
a little bit and not upset the folks of
china because they may come after you so
you know i don't know if you guys are
getting to my drift you know it's a
little too much tom you're offending my
friends of china
okay and if you piss them off they will
come and they will find you
similar to the line from the girl in
wedding crashes i will find you
okay if you remember that scene i don't
know if you could probably i didn't know
because a wife that did that that's
right she's a beast by the way
i did i didn't see uh wedding crashers
no i mean it's a very it's a highly
recommended by the way guys
christian.com
there might be a pg version of it out
there somewhere yeah
it's 13 minutes long edited it's the
credits
there there's some kind of a wisdom in
that movie there's some kind of wisdom
in that movie they could take away okay
all right so
let's skip this china topic tom and
we'll go to another topic that we have
here how about let's talk about china
taking over the world
because we haven't really did we get
into the numbers with china being the
biggest economy in the world or not yet
we haven't done that
okay another painful pandemic side
effect china's economy is now set to
pass u.s in 2020 it has world's
largest in an intriguing twist the
covenant pandemic which has its roots in
china
is a primary reason the chinese economy
is expected to overtake
that of the us within a few years a
report said china's
decisive actions at the outset of the
outbreak combined with the disastrous
effects on the american economy
are keys chinese president xi jinping
said last month that a doubling of this
country's economy was entirely possible
by 2035
under his five-year plan for an improved
brand of socialism
japan would stay at number three for
another 10 years before india takes that
spot
germany would drop to number five the
report u.s growth slung to 1.9 percent
per year between 2022
and 2024 and then a 1.6 which is even
lower
the yearly expectation for chinese
growth is 5.7
from 2021 to 2025 then 4.5
from 2026 to 2030 with a trend slowing
down to 3.9 but still two to four
percent
faster than the u.s economy are we one
day soon gonna look at china as the
biggest economy in the world
yes absolutely it's going to be
and the rest of the world using china as
this factory is letting it happen
you know when the jobs and manufacturing
jobs are over there and that's why you
have
cheaper products over here if you take
that away
it's uh you know prices go up on a lot
of goods it's going to be the largest
economy
it's going to happen i'm frankly shocked
it's not sooner than that and i think it
might be
i think if depending on what happens in
georgia and what happens here in the
next three four years it may happen by
2024.
that would not shock me and here's the
difference china everything they do
is proactive everything we do is
reactive we bicker amongst ourselves we
think we're our own worst enemy china
knows who their enemy is it's the rest
of the world
and they unite and they go after and
they have a plan i mean everything
is used as leverage for them they're
just smart about everything including
the pandemic
all right it's almost like they knew
about it or something um
so yeah it doesn't surprise me at all
look at the population difference
you know they already have that built-in
advantage look at the other
key factor is california which is the
world's fifth biggest economy on its own
is slowly slipping into the toilet so
yeah that's gonna have a big effect on
everything as well so yeah this is going
to happen it might happen sooner than
these economists think
what does that mean though if it does
happen what does it mean if it does
happen
is there any thing to it is the american
dream
going to be getting a black eye is it
going to be
is a book going to be coming out titled
the chinese dream
no but is that what it's going to come
out the chinese dream
replaces the american dream that's how
they'll spin it for sure but it will be
a 100 percent
a testimony to the fact that whatever
we've done to fall into second place
isn't working and you know what it's
just ego-wise
we don't want to be second in economy
we're america
come on
i don't think life in america will be
altered one bit by the leaderboard of
the world economies
i think you've still got freedom free
enterprise and people here are going to
dig it they're not going to say
wow i never said that i disagree with
that as well because i think china's
going to use that
and think that they can be number one in
everything in the military i think it's
going to be
well that's different you're talking
about you know
you know average zone united states
i i think it's going to be china will
use that information
forget about china forget about china
there's one thing you guys are fully
missing
and not not not thinking about okay so
imagine it's 2032
and your kids are going to school
they're going to uc berkeley
they're going to whatever place they're
going to okay and professor
johnson mary johnson is up there
teaching economy
and she says for decades
america kept telling people that the
best system in the world was capitalism
well guess what
china proved that it doesn't work china
proved that the right way to run a
country
to consider is communistic at the top
and socialistic at the bottom
to think about the people and america
only thought about the rich people and
this is why america eventually lost
and now china is bigger than america so
to all your capitalist
uncles and you know fathers that we're
talking about america is the greatest
country in the world
i hate to spell it to you boys and girls
they were wrong
and your 19 year old kid who you're
spending at that time 107 000
a year to go to school is sitting there
saying mom my teacher today
you know miss mary johnson said the fact
that capitalism sucks and she's right
because if capitalism so good
why did china pass up the u.s economy
why
maybe we need to consider some of these
principles in karl marx communist
manifesto
we need to look at the fact that
communism and socialism isn't really
that bad
maybe these americans all they care
about is money you
are going to see teachers run with this
like you've nev richard wolff will be
a celebrity richard wolfe is going to
come out saying
i told you so and all the capitalist
author the arthur c brooks the milton
friedman community that comes from that
lineage the thomas seoul community that
comes from there
they're going to be sitting there saying
well because china has 1.6 billion
people and mark only has 300
all those arguments are going to be made
and every time they're going to say but
china passed you up but china passed you
up but china passed you up
you don't think that's going to have a
negative impact for the next 20 30 40
years of the way kids are going to go to
school
really i don't know about that guys and
this is coming from a guy that's a
capitalist well they're probably already
doing it the mary johnsons of the world
but the morning johnson
don't have an argument yet because they
haven't passed up yet what happens if
they do pass u.s economy up
or when they do and then will we ever be
able to catch them again tom looks like
you want to say something
i hear you and i think it's going to be
spun that way and i think it's going to
be seen that way and it's just uh
you know i think it's it's going to be
like the remnant you know
we're all the remnant out there trying
to
tell the story and trying to help people
understand there's a better way
i like the uh the the scenario with the
conversation very
visually you didn't go there you didn't
go there visually you want to see it you
you seriously tom
you are a capitalist i am a capitalist
tom's a capitalist
you didn't because look okay so so
remember this let me go back to what the
guy that i interviewed
uh who said who are the top five most
powerful uh
organizations in america remember what
he said number one was
number one was uh uh did he say uh who
did he say as number one
was social number one no social was the
number one president was number three or
four
oh who was number one universities he
said number one okay
then he went to social number two uh new
universities congress
president social then mainstream media
he actually didn't think mainstream
media was as powerful as he thought
social was above the rest of the
rest of the guys but if he is saying
universities
and if universities are getting an
innocent
17 18 year old kid that comes to them
for four years and they can
indoctrinate a certain mindset into them
how long does it take to get them away
from that mindset meaning you know the
whole saying that goes
if you're young you know and uh uh
what's the quote that says if you're
young and democrat makes sense if you're
old and
oh if you're if you're young and a
republican you have no heart if you're
old and you're a democrat you have no
brain yeah
if you're young and republican you have
no heart if you're old and democrat you
have no brain right okay
how long does it take after a kid goes
to school and after coming out of school
and again to the
whole thing about rich people saw
capitalism sucks all this stuff how long
does it take for them to finally say
[ __ ] i don't agree with my teacher how
long does that typically take what's the
time like can we say 10 or 15 years
is that probably a good timeline um no i
had
i i knew friends when i was getting my
mba not you don't think about you i'm
talking about the average person that
gets that not tom ellsworth got it so
you get out at 22 years old
and you are saying rich people are bad
they're greedy all they care about is
themselves not over
these other social countries are more
about their people than america is
after 22 years old how long takes the
average
four-year graduate until they realize
capitalism is actually pretty good is it
10 years
is it like 32 by 35 by 40. i think it's
five to ten years because
i i know of a lot of a lot of folks
in silicon valley that are two-sided you
know on one side they
they want wealth they want things they
want to aspire they want to be an owner
they want a vc to invest in their
company
and they want those fruits on the other
side they do feel very passionate about
you know racial equality equality for
women and moving these
these social agenda things forward that
they think are
right and they are right and they are
important it's things that we need to
progress on but but inside they'll tell
you they may not like
some of the some of the fallout of
capitalism
but they all want to move forward and
they want to earn more
and they look at the taxes i think you
are really being naive right now got to
be honest with you tom are you really
telling me the effects of china passing
u.s and these professors using it to
absolutely crush the brains of our young
future generation do you think they're
going to take it easy no that's bad
that that's going to be the way they're
going to play that card
and they have the validity there's a
different story when somebody pitches it
this way
like think about it when somebody says
capitalism's bad
and america's very greedy and america's
not nice to people and look at all the
words that america started
right and look we are not the american
dream stop
saying the american dream you know there
was a time people hated when people said
american exceptionalism i don't know if
you remember this
this was just eight years ago we got to
stop using american exceptionalism we
got to stop talking about how
america is the greatest country in the
world what makes america great you don't
remember eight years ago when everybody
was pitching the store that america's
not great okay
so but that was being said with no
numbers to prove
that was being said without any data so
imagine when they have the data yeah
so think about today you know how people
wake up in the morning and they're kind
of like
oh man i'm censorship i'm really
concerned about censorship you know
prageru university i'm really concerned
about censorship i'm really concerned
concerned about you you want me to look
at something or i'm really concerned
about
you know where we're at with the amount
of control google facebook youtube some
of these guys i'm really concerned i'm
really concerned i'm really concerned
i'm really concerned today
[Music]
ten years from now china is number one i
don't know if it's going to be
censorship i think it's going to be
university professors that'll just be
part of it and it'll be a big part of it
no question about it but
i mean people just lose common sense
when they think about china
like look what happened in the nba last
year you know with the one tweet from
daryl mori and then now the nba just
completely shows how it bows down to
china and
you know and everybody that hates donald
trump you know get used to the fact
that you're going to have a president
that's just going to bow down to china
for the next four years
trump's the only person capable of
standing up to him
when china has the number one ranking
they control everything they control all
trade negotiations who's going to be
able to stand up to him
and that gap is only going to widen very
very quickly once they catch him
right because we're going to be chasing
and they're not you know
it could be very damaging what happens
in the next four years and let's just
say that
especially when you look at how things
have changed in the past four years and
just china's dominance and they are
coming
at this in a wave of power and a
strategic plan of what they're trying to
accomplish
and they're checking off the boxes as
they go along here
change how america thinks through social
media get control of traditional media
in the united states
you know invest in these key industries
so we can have even more sway
end of discussion bad things are coming
yeah
yeah yes then the the other side is that
even if there are capitalism professors
that are teaching that the universities
are forcing them not to
because who is the biggest sponsors for
some of the universities
china yes he is right though
china is funding some of these
universities hardcore and you're seeing
a ton of that okay so let's talk about
the top earners biggest ceo owners today
uh in america top three are microsoft
ceo satya nadella 42.9 million dollars
salary
uh number three number two is uh uh wait
a minute so let me see top three okay
that's the one microsoft number two is
robert swan of intel 66.1 mill
66.9 million dollars at number two and a
big shock number one
the ceo of google parent company
alphabet sundar
pichai whose compensation is a fiscal
2019 total of 280
million six hundred thousand dollars
that's a salary
facebook seo mark zuckerberg 23.9 23.4
million dollars made only 94 times more
than his employees
but that's the lowest of all ceos listed
most on the list
earn several hundred times more than
their workers
so so when you hear these numbers what
do you think about it well i think you
got to just
you know draw a line in the sand and say
all right man if we are capitalist and
we believe
in in that type of you know business and
and economy
then we gotta root for them that means
they did something right that means they
had a great year
you know it it's it's touchy i think i
look at it simply this it's a scoreboard
it's a fun little thing to look at at
the end of the year
it's so far off in the stratosphere for
for most people there's nothing you can
do about it
it's just mind-boggling to think of some
of these numbers and and how about the
guy
you got to give sunday uh however you
pronounce his name
the head of alphabet credit for staying
under the radar screen the guy's never
in the news
you never hear about them very very very
in the background
and that's a that's a hefty compensation
but you also have to read between the
lines a little bit and that's not their
salary i mean they're cashing in stock
and it's bonuses and it's incentive so
you know more power to them
yeah i think when you break it down i
think the media likes to talk about
these
big numbers oh my gosh it makes so much
more but a lot of it is
stock compensation and if the company
didn't go up why aren't any airline ceos
on there i'd be willing to bet there's
one or two airline ceos that have a
higher
cash based salary with medical benefits
a bunch of perks
than some of these guys listed but they
didn't have the the stock based
compensation that went with it that
drove it
up and so you know i think it's a bit of
a vanity stat
but it is to the victor in terms of
building
enterprise value and that's what um
that's what these guys are paid to do
is drive michael m has been saying what
i've been hinting at you the entire
podcast
will the real tom ellsworth please stand
up and he gave 10 bucks
okay i agree with you michael i think
tom's playing safe today
okay and i'm going crazy here give your
brain to
us buddy i just i'm just giving a f
everything is a 15 second one-liner
thomas
we're trying to learn from you i call
tom by the way if you if camera's off
i'm having lunch with tom yesterday we i
don't know where we were yesterday or
two days whatever it was anyways we had
lunch last week or yesterday we had
lunch
and i sit there and i walk away two
hours later
smarter every single time every single
time times are modern-day wikipedia
tom's brain when he processes stuff but
on the podcast
tom's you know tom's a little bit uh you
know i don't know what happened what did
you eat your breakfast you eat your
wheaties today did you have it because
tom give us the real
run now so i'm going to ask a question a
different way from you okay please
give us the tom hill's word that then
give us a damn real quick okay
can we get a damn okay tom today
i think it's fair to say one of the
biggest criticisms
that ceos get like yesterday guy sends
me a message saying it's unfair that
zuckerberg's is making this much more
times than his employees are
and these ceos are making a hundred
times more than their employees are et
cetera et cetera right
so we're bashing these guys that are
making money so here's a question
if i'm a kid okay we're in college
if we're in college and we're partying
together
and we're going out there we're having a
drink or whatever we're doing okay we're
going
obviously something you never did
because i know you were very
conservative but so
so yeah exactly a different uh type of
partying
which i i'm willing to bet tom knows
more about weed than anybody in this
room combined i am willing to bet tom
knows more about wheat than anybody he
can do clinic you can do case study on
it
but let me go back to my question here
when we're in college
when we're in high school when you're
hanging out with your buddies
what do you what do you dream about what
do you sit there and say you say one day
i want to be what hey johnny what do you
want to be when you grow up what do you
want to do what do we talk about
be rich yeah you want to be what dude i
want to be like mike i want to be like
mike was one of them right i won't be
like mike okay who do you want to be
who who did you want to be when you were
in high school we're in 11th grade with
you kyle what was your dream what would
you say
what was your sam what was yours you
know maybe sam from colombia said i want
to be like pablo
when i grew up i don't know what's
what's your dream paul you said you
wanted to be who
is it arnold yes you wanted to be arnold
the greatest bodybuilder of all time
sam what was yours you wanted to be what
top ceo of a company
top c of a company okay was that really
yours is that really yours what's yours
i wanted to be the next denzel
washington you wanted to be an ex denzel
washington what was yours
in high school yes i was going to take
that seriously down yeah seriously what
was that honestly yes freaking awesome
what was yours
when i was in when i was in high school
in high school were in high school where
lunch we're having
grilled cheese you know whatever pizza
we're having whatever good food they
give to high school kids
who's tom want to be i had read about
the birth of microsoft and i wanted
somehow to be part of a tech company
okay
freaking do you realize like we all
dreamt about one day being
somebody important right right and now i
am so confused when the media says these
guys are
getting overpaid there's an element of
me as a kid
that wants to think about somebody
getting overpaid
there's there's an element of a kid
dreaming about saying i want to see one
guy score more points than everybody
else
like can you imagine this question would
you like to see somebody beat the will
chamberlain record of a hundred hundred
points
would you like to see i would would you
want would you want to see would you
want to see somebody beat the 74
home run record with barry bonds without
steroids a 220 pound skinny guy doing 75
home runs would you like to see
that yes would you like to see joe
dimaggio's 56 game hit streak being
broken
would you like to see somebody you know
win five world series in a row and maybe
it's never
been done before would you like to see
somebody get seven rings and someone
went four pete not three p
we wanna see these records being taken
place i don't understand the logic
behind
saying this is too much money they're
making
because it's not good for society to
have somebody make this much more money
well why don't you since you feel you
can do better
why don't you go create a website that
has three billion users
if you do that we'll pay you handsomely
why don't you
go become so good at what you do where
you become the ceo of the number one
search engine in the world
you go do it if you can do that props to
you maybe you these are 400 million
dollar compensation
why are we so much about criticizing
people who win at the highest level in
america i'm so confused
why maybe one of the reasons is some of
these people are unlikable and they're
tech companies and they're hard to root
for so that could be one small reason
but
the media just in general that that's
their mentality they always want to root
against the big guy
they want safe they want you know these
aren't big thinkers we're talking about
in media that are writing these stories
so
you know it's always that us versus them
mentality
i i okay the real me
you know i will tell you something and i
wasn't being safe i was being honest
what i said
if you take a look at what some of these
ceos make just the cash compensation
there's a there's a
a lot of alignment across industries but
the airlines didn't go up and so the
stock didn't go up and so they didn't
make all the extra money so they're not
on the
hit list of overpaid overpaid leader
punks that everybody wants to call them
out to be but i got to say this
i am glad that mark zuckerberg made what
he made
because it meant the value of that
company was increased number one and
number two
he made a hell of a lot of jobs you may
not like what all those jobs are doing
in terms of censoring and things like
that
but he made a bunch of jobs i am glad
that google
is made that that guy you know sundar
made the money
because it means that google is still
expanding there's jobs that are being
created i see that side of it from an
entrepreneurial lens
and i tell people really well let me
tell you a world without billionaires
means we all eat ramen noodles do you
really want that
do you want that no nobody wants that
and so that's that's how i feel about
that it's like
it's easy to be envious of the other guy
when
some people are a little too critical or
a little too lazy or a little too
envious or a little too jealous
it's easy to be critical but then you
gotta step back and look at it
and you know for every google you talk
about oh
you remember the auto industry and it
decimated flint michigan because they
got out competed against and then it
went down
and now look at flint yeah but you know
what people had jobs in flint and front
was built and
the world changed and you know
the rust belt and u.s steel went and
these are cycles and they hurt and
they're bad
and people talk about them like that but
you know you're just
criticizing the people at the beginning
you know the jobs are crazy you know who
makes this mistake the most and they
don't even know how costly the mistake
is
you know who makes this mistake the most
and it's so costly
parents parents
parents make the mistake imagine this
kid's dream is to one day be a sunday
a sunday imagine this kid's dream is to
one day be a ceo of
you know a facebook imagine the sketch
and the mom says these
rich people let me tell you these rich
people
and the kid says mom i kind of wanted to
do to impress you
now mom made no incentive for this kid
to do that
and long term he could have been the
winning ticket for the entire family
but the parent killed the kids
dream let the kid dream
on what he wants to do i think that's
who ends up paying the biggest price and
they don't even know
you know uh i interviewed you you know
the whole no more mr nice guy the book i
don't
even end up getting it or not i bought
it did you read it you felt he was
talking to me
did you read it no i did i i did it
started off with a bang
there's no question i'd say the first 80
pages outstanding got a little clinical
in the middle maybe it
ran out of things to say picked up at
the end so i thought it was a very good
book so what'd you think was it a good
book no i think it was
did it give you some perspective you
didn't think about before no i literally
the guy with his background with with
everything he's observing he kind of
talked to you a little bit i mean
i think anybody can look at that book
and say there might be a little bit
about me
i agree so i interviewed the guy last
week okay he reached out
my booker allen who's ridiculous he
listens to everything we do and he just
kind of reaches out to people he says
hey i got the guy
let's do the interview so we do the
interview okay while we're doing the
interview i said so you know tell me
about
you know how big of a role we talk about
real interesting stuff i said how big of
a role does the first time you ever have
sex to
have to do with uh uh us for the rest of
our lives he says
everything i said so that means we're
all screwed
yes your first sexual experience ruins
your life
i said okay so we went through
especially if you were alone at the time
well that's that's he said that's okay
we talked about that as well by the way
i know what you're saying about that we
talked about that as well
but you know one of the things i said so
what do you say about parenting
he says here's the thing with parenting
just
make sure you're gonna screw your kids
up just make sure it's not too much
okay what interesting feedback you're
going to screw your kids up
just don't think just don't do it too
much because
if you do too much these kids are going
to be grown up worried about walking on
eggshells this egg shows that extra this
you know i think when you see something
like this you know i wonder what kids
are talking about with their parents at
their house
you know if you're sitting at the dinner
table and mom says rich people are bad
dad says rich people are greedy these
people these people that kid is kind of
like
yeah you know so maybe the best guy that
could have ran
a great company been a great co done a
thing better than elon musk or any of
these guys did
maybe maybe that nurturing maybe that
challenge and that pushing maybe that
wasn't there i don't know
well plus maybe i'm fully off if you
have the drive to do that you're
probably going to overcome some of those
negative
you know impulses you're getting from
their parents or whatnot but you know
you mentioned you know your interview
with the guy that wrote mr nice guy
talking about your first sexual
experience i was listening to
a different podcast victory the podcast
which is about entourage all the guys
from entre
so if you like entourage it's a great
podcast with doug ellen
and they had james kahn on the show
because scott khan
used to be on entourage right the actor
yes so james khan was on there talking
about and
man have times changed but when scott
khan turned 16
james khan got him a sweet at the four
seasons and brought in a couple of heidi
fleisch's girls
hey you're 16 now so can you imagine his
first sexual experience is with a couple
of heidi fleisch's girl
you know what charlie sheens was charlie
sheen used his dad's credit card to get
a couple prostitutes
that's what charlie she did and it's
that's like what's this mindset i got a
couple prizes
can you imagine like everybody has a
different story with the first
experience but
he said it has such a big impact of who
you become
so again half the battle list by the way
i can't wait for people to see that
interview because
it was very very different the things we
talked about is very different on what
shapes
boys to become men and some men still
have their own boy tendencies but by the
way pat if
if you ever want to hear a good james
khan story i have one i don't i don't
want to slow down these podcasts
don't tell them okay james khan
godfather i'm just the legendary actor
so i this was probably 12 years ago and
i was having dinner in l.a with um byron
allen
big time tv guy we were talking about
this magazine i had at the time and the
restaurant was morton so the restaurant
was pretty much empty it was a wednesday
no it is in there my really good friend
john kelly who was the
the host of extra at the time was going
to come and meet us because he knew
james khan from interviewing him so many
times
uh no he was going to come because byron
was there we looked behind us there's
one other table it was
um james khan and
george hamilton so they were in the
table right behind us and i love james
khan
it was right when that tv show vegas was
out you know on nbc and whatnot but i
just love james conn
so i had my magazine issues spread out
all over the table and i go john we got
can you introduce james con to me he
goes yeah yeah i'll bring him over so he
brings him over
james khan comes over just like you'd
think hands in his pockets just mr cool
good looking magazine there kid nice
looking magazine
good paper great job good job i took it
too far
i go hey james such a pleasure to meet
you man love you
god you're such a legend hey ed devine
in vegas you know
he literally stopped looked at me he
goes direct quote he goes
i've been in 65 pictures including the
godfather and you want to [ __ ] bust
my balls on ed divine
in las vegas that's literally what he
said to me i thought he was going to
take me out
but i don't know if he was joking or if
he was really ticked off or he could
switch
let's leave afterwards yeah he kind of
walked out i mean it's not
or anything like that no autograph no
photos so i think i did offend him
accidentally i love james khan wow yeah
i mean there's there's a lot of stories
with james khan he's got a lot of
interest in johnny
johnny russo told me a story about james
come one time uh that when you
when they were making a godfather james
khan wasn't happy the fact that johnny
russo knew everybody at staten island
because that's where you know
johnny russo was from and they had a
beef so the scene about when james con
is beating him up yeah
he says he wasn't just that was an actor
he was actually really trying to hurt me
because we didn't like each other he
didn't like me for one reason
anyways so let's go with that to
mario's quote i want to quote him
directly the number one movie
box office during the pandemic we have
to give credit to mario because
that's mario is that mario's quote yes
or no i think mark i think i think it's
mario's quote
mario is definitely listening to this
here wonder woman 1984 opening boosts
movie theater stocks but amc loses
more ground the better than expected
christmas weekend opening for wonder
woman 1984
is giving most exhibition stocks a
welcome boost as the misery of 2020
gives hope to
hope for brighter 2021 shares on the
center mark imax marcus corp
the national center media rose between
three to seven percent of peace
after the sequel took 16.7 million
dollars domestically
the best bow by any film during the
coronavirus pandemic amc the world's
largest
theater circuit was a notable execution
exception for the
to the rally its stock dropped five
percent on the ongoing investor concern
that is liquidity
and a potential bankruptcy filing yeah
2.38 cents
2.38 amc shares are at the lowest since
early november
they are still a notch above 2020 bottom
of 195
established in mid-march of cover 19
shuttered theaters across the western
hemisphere etc etc
the first movie opened at 103 million
dollars this is the first wonder woman
did 103 million dollars grossed
eventually
8 21 worldwide making it the 10th
highest grossing film of 2017 however
uh gal gadot was only paid three hundred
thousand dollars in the first one pretty
crazy to think she only got paid 200 000
wonder woman uh 1984. 16.7 million
and gal gadot got paid 10 million
dollars which is good for her
so wonder woman have either one of the
guests i've not seen no i've not seen
anything has anybody seen it here have
you guys seen it have you seen it kyle
you've seen it yeah you liked it
it was all right i mean i have my gripes
but zero to ten
zero to ten uh maybe like a seven
did you stream it or go to seven did you
go to the theater no i went i was on hbo
okay
okay so you give it a six and a half
seven six would you give to the first
one
this first one was pretty solid i'd give
the first one more of like
eight okay so i watched the first one
two weeks ago with my kids because each
week our kids get a turn for movies
so dylan got the turn dylan wanted to
watch wonder woman anyways we watched
wonder woman and he enjoyed it and kids
enjoyed it
and then we went to watch wonder woman
1984 in fort lauderdale this last week
and i got to tell you i loved the movie
i
loved the movie i didn't like the movie
i loved the movie and
to be fair not everybody who went with
me
felt the way i did okay my sister didn't
feel the same way my brother-in-law
didn't feel the same way some of the
people were like it's an okay movie they
didn't say it's a great movie
i thought it was a ridiculous movie
phenomenal movie a part of the movie i
liked
is there's this scene with barbara i
think it's the girl's name right
barbara's the
the new girl that's working and working
with the fbi is that kristen wiig
i think that's who is she the one that
played in bridemaids
yes yes okay her yeah so her name is
barbara and she plays the role of this
girl that comes in very
no guy talks to her she's not attractive
et cetera et cetera
and then she meets you know a super uh
what do you call it
a wonder woman right and so she sees how
she reacts and she oh my gosh she's so
amazing
and there's this rock there's the stone
that they get that whatever you touch
you can make your wish and it becomes a
reality so
wonder woman makes her wish okay then
gaga doe
makes her wish i'm not going to tell you
the whole story but i'll tell you guys
what the the barbara's wish was to one
day be
like the wonder woman so what happens
she starts becoming like wonder woman
and what ends up happening to her she
flips she becomes dark
evil because too much power being given
too fast what it could do to you
and then the whole message becomes at
the end of the day that
be careful what you wish for you know
you got to be careful what you wish for
and i think the storyline at the end on
how it brought everything together and
evil became good and
evil finally realized that he loves his
son and all he wanted to do was impress
his son and his son just wanted love
from his dad and
there was so many great messages to this
movie
interesting that i thought it was a
phenomenal storyline to watch with your
kids with your family because it touched
on all the emotions
so i thought it was a great movie and
i'm surprised it only did 16 million
dollars but not surprised because
most people just went to hbo max to
watch the movie let me let me throw
something out
here and i'm going to take a little bit
bigger picture look at this thing and
i'm going to tell you something i
believe hollywood has a very big problem
on their hands
and it's not the pandemics shutting down
theaters it's
people like me okay i will not watch
wonder woman and i'll tell you why i
don't like gil godot
i don't like her i don't like that
imagine video she put out at the
beginning of the pandemic
i find her to complete to be completely
out of touch
completely unable to read a room having
no perspective whatsoever that was the
stupidest
video i have ever seen in my life ever
i i when i think about it now i think
house stu
how did you not have any mechanism in
your brain that might think this is not
a good idea
i will not see that movie because of her
and i'll tell you another thing
at the grove remember the grove in la
great great mall you know they have
movie posters all over the place
when i was there yeah exactly right
across from cbs there's posters for
wonder woman because it's the only movie
out
she doesn't feel like a star to me guild
godot does not seem like a movie star to
me i can't buy it
so i will not see that movie now you
start compounding that by 10 and 20 and
because of the political stances these
people in hollywood are making there's
gonna be people that are gonna say i'm
not gonna see a movie because of the
rock
because of jennifer aniston because of
robert downey jr
because of will ferrell who brought the
whole elf cast to georgia
to raise money for the democratic
candidates down there that disappointed
me
they really care about what you think no
i do oh wait the rep
no i don't think they can care about
what you think but i think there's going
to be a bad there is going to be
i don't think so you're going to see it
in the background let me tell you why
i don't know if that's going to happen
or not who do you think is a bigger
victory for them you and your community
or
china china okay that's what i'm trying
to tell you
they really don't care if they lose you
if they win china they're not trying to
win you over they're not trying to win
conservatives over they're trying to do
whatever they can to win china over
anything and everything i mean if you've
seen the movie mulan the logo of huawei
is in the movie mulan all over the place
as the huawei logo have you guys noticed
it or no it's everywhere right
they're not yet they're not trying to
win you they're trying to win china
and if that's the target they're making
a lot of progress but they're all
they're also under marching orders for
how to make these movies because china
finances these films oh i know so
that yeah yeah i i don't know i just i
don't i'm not gonna watch that movie i
don't think hey
let me ask you a question do you think
you love the movie as much as you did or
you love the theater experience the
going to the movie
the fact that you could actually be
there and do it and enjoy yourself i'm a
movie guy and i like movies that produce
emotions and have the right uh
uh story lines that makes you think i'm
the guy the mario
tom and i one time watched a uh
churchill movie
at the look theater we came out i was in
tears i was fired up i was emotional i
was do you remember that
dunker yeah oh my gosh man i was on fire
that night
i couldn't even sleep all night long
just thinking about it right
to see that somebody was willing to
stand up to evil and look what ended up
happening to it because of him
we speak english we don't speak german
the world could have been a lot of
a very different place if he wouldn't
have the courage to do what he did and
his
troops didn't follow the orders that was
given from the top
you know to me a good movie that
produces good emotions i appreciate it i
actually don't go too much deep into the
politics but i
i don't uh disagree with you when you
look what happened with me and the
lakers and lebron and you know how
things happen this year
but i don't really think they care tom i
think they're okay losing you
yeah because they're trying to win china
but there's a lot of me's and that adds
up to a lot of
us domestic box office there's not 1.6
billion of you
true yeah that's the difference thoughts
you went on a rant man you don't like
that
yeah i'm have to write this down i will
not watch her with a mouse i will not
watch her in a house i will not watch
her
take a stand to get certain things i
will not
are you guys gonna convince me that
she's a movie star is she am i missing
the boat here
i don't really i honestly the thought
didn't even cross my mind
i just went in to watch a good movie and
the story was good and i enjoyed it
tom fifty percent of movies i watch i
fall asleep not one time did i fall
asleep
shift out the comfortable chairs not one
time do i fall asleep they had my
attention for the entire two and a half
hours
that's a good rating system yeah how
many z's you know i i fall asleep asap i
mean i
15 minutes you don't get me i'm gone
kyle you want to say something yeah
yeah i find it interesting to top this
for you tom that
you can't separate the artist from the
art i saw some of the comments in the in
the stream from that because let me
there's some of my favorite actors i
don't necessarily agree with politically
i mean
i love tom cruise as an action actor i
grew up on mission impossible i love his
sci-fi films oblivion edge of tomorrow
world worlds all that stuff but i don't
agree with him as a scientologist
but when i watch the films you know
that's the whole point of like the
acting is that
i get to see tom cruise right i'm seeing
whoever he's playing
yeah but you know that's easier said
than done because everybody's got human
nature in them and that is going to
affect them i agree with that
yeah you know it's crazy yesterday tom
was telling me a story he said
there is a guy there's only one person
in hollywood that has a four
uh uh uh older woman
he wins younger women older men younger
men there's only one actor tommy what's
that no it's only one actor that has
what do they call them four blocks yep
foursquare actor and it's high positives
and all
four that will draw viewership i'm just
throwing names out there
a current actor yeah you're going to
have well it's the biggest one give the
biggest one who's the biggest name that
made the most money the last three years
uh he was a former wrestler
non-conference correct
of course he's number one and
non-controversial and then you know what
question i asked him i said that's
interesting you say that said do you
think it was a good move for him to
endorse joe biden he says no because he
went against his
philosophy so there is an element of
hurting their brand if they do that
yeah and so there is and let's take it
one step further was that raw i mean
his endorsement was a i really don't
like to do this i really don't want to
do this but i have to do this i'm going
to go with joe biden it wasn't really a
heartfelt passionate thing so
there could i mean you could go into
this how these movies are financed who's
controlling him
is it you know in somebody's best
interest for him to come out and say
that
yeah i think kyle some people are
worried for your safety after the
comments you made about tom cruise so
today when you're going home please go
in your car with somebody else because
you got to be careful when you say any
comments about tom because tom may be
out there right now shouting your name
saying cow
i can't believe you're doing this he may
lose his mind
yeah you're gone you're god promised
this will be the last day you have a job
okay but uh anyways guys that brings us
to the end of the podcast
uh if you enjoyed today's podcast smash
that subscribe button
we will not be doing another podcast
until
2021 so between now and next year
happy new year to all of you be safe
don't be too crazy we're expecting 2021
to become the beginning
of the greatest years of our lives and i
hope you make some big decisions the
next few days to make it yours as well
take care everyone bye bye bye bye
you